benjamin castaldi moi j'ai choqué
évidemment parce que c'est très triste
pour elle mais mais alors il ya
différents cas de figure moi je vais
vous parler en fait et on parle de
bigard que les primes d'argent qui perd
alors c'est dans la tête des gens c'est
vrai que c'est choquant parce que mon a
gagné et regan y ait effectivement
parfois beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent et on se dit mais
comment est-ce qu'on veut trouver dans
dans la merde quand on a gagné autant
d'argent pourquoi tu auras mis de
l'argent de côté et c'est fait vous
montrer un exemple qui est très simple
moi j'ai eu des problèmes parce que j'ai
fait des mauvais investissements
j'étais en fait avec les membres ont été
condamnés quand on est condamné on a des
saisies donc moi j'ai été donc saisi sur
mon salaire
moi j'avais un jet à mener est fait de
paix il y avait 22 mille euros bruts à
tf1 alors vous aviez donc 22000 euros
bruts brute de salaire une armée alors
voilà une fois que vous êtes rentré dans
le cycle où vous êtes vous êtes saisis
il vous laisse ce qui est des bosquets
une somme niveau ils vous laissent 1600
euros
sauf que moi cette époque là j'ai vingt
dix des vingt mille euros d'impôts à
payer
j'ai écrit la maison j'ai des pensions
alimentaires donc j'ai un train de vie
assuré en fait en l'espace de 10 12 mois
vous êtes encore plus dans la merde que
vous ne l'était en fait le c-17
infernale on ne peut rien faire et quand
on prend conscience parce
qu'effectivement il ya un peu des go et
un peu d'orgueil évidemment on se dit
voilà je suis vedette ou même quand on
ouvre les yeux c'est trop tard donc moi
je me suis battu parce qu'effectivement
gt gt voilà je suis dans un combat
juridique donc j'avais d'abord c'était
épauler j'étais conseiller mais si
j'avais pas été dans cette situation là
s'il avait été un peu faible simultanée
apicole et cetera
j'aurais certainement finit très mal et
c'est pareil pour tout le monde si vous
avez 1200 euros de salaire on vous
enlève aux fins de saisie il vous reste
pas grand chose dont il faut pas il faut
pas blâmer les stars il faut juste
comprendre qu'effectivement on a mené
grand train on a fait des choses moi
effectivement j'ai profité de la vie
mais ce qui m'est arrivé je ne mérite
pas honnêtement occire et voilà
aujourd'hui j'ai envie j'ai fait de
mauvais d'investissement je fais un très
mauvais investissement effectivement je
n'ai pas été très prévoyants mai mais le
fait est qu au final pendant quatre ans
cyril ça a été quand je vous dis un
enfer c'est un enfer et c'est un combat
à ce que les gens ne comprennent pas ils
pensent que vous avez caché des lingots
sonos au plumard vous avez de l'argent à
l'étranger ce qui n'est pas le cas donc
maintenant j'allais me battre parce que
j'en suis arrivé à va déposer un dossier
de surendettement pour qu'on me fiche la
paix est allé déposer un dossier à sion
et qui a été acceptée parce que les gens
parce que j'ai mis très longtemps parce
que dans la tête des gens il ya la télé
tous les jours ils gagnent de l'argent
qu'indécent donc c'est indécent bien sûr
que c'est indécent
sauf que si c'était pas ça je ne peux
pas mentir aujourd'hui si on veut si on
me laisse pas respirer un peu je vais
crever magique vous n'aviez pas mon nez
même tapis même plus de carte bleue non
mais j'ai moi j'ai connu j'ai connu un
certain que c'est qu'effectivement gt
carte bleue et oui y'a pas un vandale
qui sort alors sa pas durer ça peut
durer des années mais pas mis à la
planche j'avais emprunté à tous vos
potes donc vous n'avez plus personne
vers qui vous vous retournez
effectivement pendant pendant un mois il
y avait plus de chauffage à la maison
mais comment j'avais pu penser un jour
que j'ai imaginé le nombre de gens qui
sont dans votre cas mais c'est donc
quand je vois si ce temps là je
comprends très bien moi je me souviens
les vingt ans venait il y avait sept
cette couverture parce que on pouvait
pas chauffé je vais pas faire le plein
mais quand vous racontez ça on ne peut
pas vous croire je vous le dis
franchement on ne vous croit pas vous
allez dans des justes qui ne vous crois
pas parce que c'est pas parce que c'est
pas audible ses rides c'est vrai que
c'est pas audible quand on a eu la
carrière que j'ai eue quand on a fait ce
que l'effet sais pas répond tous les
artistes quand ils ont fait ce qu'ils
ont fait dans leur vie on ne peut pas
entendre qu'un jour ça n'aille pas et
pourtant je vous le dit parfois
alors il ya ceux qui font des grosses
bêtises mais non mais souvent c'est pas
tellement des bêtises qu'on la roue se
met à tourner et qu'effectivement vous
êtes dans un dans un engrenage où on
vous avoue prendre la gorge c'est
terminé et c'est pareil pour tout le
monde que vous veniez cent mille dix
mille 5000 ou 1000 c'est la même chose
pour tout le monde et tous les gens qui
sont dans la merde parce
qu'effectivement ils ont fait un petit
crédit pour le pour le téléviseur un
pour la bagnole 1 pour les exons leur
dit un jour monsieur monsieur c'est fini
eh ben ce moment-là qu'est ce qui se
passe
vous avez les huissiers vous avez des
comptes saisie les salaires saisis on
vous prend tout ce que vous avez et
s'est terminée fin de l'histoire alors
moi j'ai pu me battre parce que
effectivement j'étais conseiller mais il
ya plein de gens quand on vous êtes pris
là donc c'est un enfer il faut bien
comprendre que c'est valable pour tout
le monde même si c'est difficile à
entendre
c'est pareil pour tout le monde est-ce
que vous avez vous avez des mecs qui
vous ont aidé des bien sûr mais
évidemment mais évidemment il ya turquie
vont prêter de l'argent doit encore je
dois beaucoup d'argent à plein de l'or
parce qu'ils m'ont aidé au moins il
fallait m'aider mais c'est très c'est
très mignon et encore une fois c'est
compliqué de venir ici j'ai put une
mémoire il me laissait quasiment rien
comme on se fait alors un mois deux mois
trois mois et c'est très compliqué et
vous le savez puisque h2o vous allez je
vous avais des saisies qui arrive très
régulièrement
on va pas se mentir effectivement c'est
très compliqué